the New York Times tries to veto your
afternoon mojito billions of Americans
enjoy day drinking in the summertime as
well as the winter time the springtime
and of course the fall time
but according to the New York Times
there's never been a robust clinical
trial evaluating its health effects
of day drinking
so they got right to work doing what
they do
I mean out of all of us
but they didn't even think to go to the
trouble of offering any new insights
instead they just slapped together some
obvious observations like did you know
drinking while the sun is out makes you
more likely to become dehydrated
and here's the kicker it's worse it gets
worse in the summer
I know I know no kidding seriously
drinking alcohol under the hot sun it
can make you lightheaded and woozy but I
mean my dad told me that when I was
seven
yeah we like to party
the author also warns us that the
earlier the drinking starts the sooner
the hangover begins
so that's how time works
foreign
course the best way to prevent hangovers
is never to drink or and here's my
secret never stop
but look if I wanted to be alert and
clear-headed in the daytime I do what
Emily does and take speed
[Laughter]
just kidding yeah
that was a long pause there she looked
at me like you always you already made
fun of me about being Speedy oh now
people are gonna so um cat uh
we've had this discussion day drinking
is better than night drinking and I
think it's I don't think it even comes
close you got speed well yes well you
need speed in the daytime well it's a
lot it's about so much more than the
alcohol and the date it's you know
you're usually outside
you know it's happy you have the day off
work those are the things that make it
awesome I mean that's why I like taking
shots in your bath in the bathroom of
your office at your data entry job
that's technically day drinking yeah it
is but that's not happy no that's not
happy at all yeah yeah I mean look at
they're having fun if you have a glass
I've noticed this I don't drink in the
daytime
but
Tyrus I will like if I decide I'm gonna
have a glass of wine from lunch my whole
world changes not afterwards but dirt I
feel like my God I can control my
destiny I don't have to live this life
the way it is I'm gonna have a glass of
wine maybe two maybe I might make a
phone call you will make the phone call
but then I might call instead you will I
might have an emergency I might somebody
might have to pick me up this is what he
does and it's usually in text messages
does everyone like me is anyone mad at
me do you know you know I want to know
I feel like you don't like me you stare
at me a lot is that my dude's gonna make
you mad
alcohol that's mine ever I think my
driver's mad at me because I'm making
him wait because I want one more glass
of wine
I don't talk to my girl this much bro
like listen my argument's all this my if
I was allowed to rebuttal I just tell
the New York Times It's Five O'Clock
Somewhere relax go have it go have a sip
do one drink a bite or something
it's done
it is I think the problem I think what
makes people feel bad about day drinking
is it puts off all the chores that
you're going to do or the things you had
they don't get invited yeah that's true
that's true yeah that's why every
Saturday is when I do all of my chores
and errands and so every Sunday is
Sunday Funday guilt-free I love day
drinking for all of those reasons that
we went over there it's fantastic
everything is Happy Everything is joyful
and you get to bed still at the same
time and then you get up to work it's
great it's phenomenal all of the New
York Times needs a drink and it reminds
me of that song by Jason Aldean where he
talks about how his girlfriend is like
stop drinking and then he the refrain is
so I don't drink anymore and I don't
drink any less that's what I want to say
in the New York Times that's a great
story
I don't know who that is who's Jason
Aldean
instead of about politics yeah do you
like me to play it that's gonna be the
one thing about the show that makes
everybody mad at you
yes exactly so Kirk do you do you don't
drink do you no during the day no
there's white claw and uh sativa yeah
they gotta work no Indica I'm working
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know the
difference between the two well you kind
of just it's a better parent
but you can work on in one you can was
this article against day drinking I
didn't I didn't really get it I thought
it seemed like a guy just graduated high
school or something like why does it
feel weird how did you know when you're
drinking today
no it is it was like it was like a
project yeah and nobody did it did they
get any they got no data like a bad guy
yeah they did they found that if you
drink in the day you'll be drunk in the
day yeah you know what I thought it's
gonna be that was a brunch he didn't get
invited and then he went to work the
next day and said Day Drinking stupid
and dangerous and anyone does it is dumb
that's what's up he didn't get to
getting invited Emily Sunday Funday
so he was wrote it was a sheep I'm being
told it was a she which which makes it
even which makes it makes more sense it
proves my point it was bitter beer face
wait I thought it was gonna be like it's
because of climate change I swear to God
gardening is going to cause best thing
about day drinking is if you're done by
like seven o'clock or six you're fine
the next day there's no hangover we
should be drinking in the day and not
drinking at night that's the solution to
all of our problems
by God
we would have no Wars we'd have no Wars
everybody to be abuzzed as hell yeah
we'd have no Wars the only reason that
one was legal because you could still
have wars on it yes exactly well all
right we got to move on coming up they
played their hunches while floozies
threw punches hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else